[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without me I'll tell you what
Montreal is a city that is
unapologetically beautiful and that's
where we're alive right now my name is
Joshua fields Melbourne and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and we are live in Montreal
well thank you welcome to the minimalist
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less
usually we take callers but instead we
don't want you have to pull out your
phone right now we have a microphone
right over here I'm sure a spotlight
will illuminate it it will look very
angelic and it looks like we already
have a few people lined up that is good
news but before we get to those
questions we have a very special guest
tonight a person who's been influential
to both of us he is a New York Times
bestselling author he is a CEO of a very
large tech startup now we're gonna talk
a lot about that and he's a good friend
of ours as well
ladies and gentlemen oh yeah and he's a
local guy ladies and gentlemen Julian
Smith
all right so we were down in the green
room earlier and I kept starting to ask
Julian questions I'm like save it I've
got to save it I've got to save it so
here's the first thing I can tell you
when when I describe Julian's work to
people which I've done many times he
wrote a book called the flinch which if
you haven't read read it it was written
like one tweet at a time but the way I
described Julian's work and what he used
to do and we'll get to that in a moment
how he transitioned of what he's doing
now but I think there's some people like
me and Ryan sometimes will like will
hold your hand across the finish line
right I'm not gonna drag you kicking and
screaming into success but I will I will
hold your hand and help you across but
but Julian will pick you up he will
shake the hell out of you and he'll set
you down and you will he's one of the
few people you'll actually thank for
doing something like that it's it's it's
it's quite the skill and and the book
the flinch and also used to blog I was
gonna say you blogged but you're one of
the people who inspired us to even start
our our blog at all I mean I remember
being in the corporate world and I
needed that shaking I needed someone to
sort of pick me up and say what the [ __ ]
are you doing with your life and I think
you probably said that verbatim to
people at least writing online and you
were able to do that in a way that I
didn't I wasn't offended by it it made
me sort of look in the mirror and say oh
yeah that that is a question I should be
asking earlier during the talk when I
was talking about there are some
difficult questions we have to ask
ourselves as opposed to just sort of
going with the flow
easing through life and I wasn't asking
those questions so first of all I just
want to acknowledge you and say thank
you for helping me ask some of those
questions and then thank you yeah he was
like a total huge inspiration to all of
this this is really weird for me guys
right now
thank you thank you yeah for sure so
let's let's talk about three years ago
this month and I just I know this
because on the drive up from Ottawa
today
III looked him like it's been such a
long time since I've read anything
online from Julian three years ago this
month was your last blog post yeah
that's right yeah and you transition
because you you started a tech startup
you had an idea for a company called
breather can you tell me a little bit
about breather cuz I'll explain it like
this it's it's air B&B for office space
but I'm that doesn't do it justice I
mean the short version is is I had
y'all's life for a form of y'all's life
for like many many years our current
life where you weren't blogging and and
he is podcasting before it was called
podcasting by the way a long time ago
yeah and and and and what happens and I
think your idea of the the deliberate
life that you all have chosen to live
and to guide people with and I think
inspires a lot of people it's something
that I took really seriously and at some
point I was like am I going to do this
forever
and and I think you have these moments
and and you think to yourself what if I
could do something else what if I could
reinvent myself how many times can i
reinvent myself do I have do I have that
capacity am I just this or can I be
something else and and so I decide to
start a company that was based around
space that connects that allows people
to open up rooms across cities and which
now is like pretty big we've raised some
like a hundred million dollars we I have
250 employees 150 of them are here in
Canada a few of them are here in this
room and I and and our company is doing
a super well and I completely reinvented
my life
from this thing that I did before that I
still AM
this book still reaches a lot of people
which is awesome and then but I despite
the anxiety didn't despite the fear of
not knowing I started over and that was
a really powerful moment
what so I had you know one big reset
obviously when I talked about my mom
died my marriage ending and it was sort
of a it was like getting into car
crashes at once sort of right you get
sideswiped then you get hit by another
car and all of a sudden you everything's
in a tailspin it wasn't that same way
for you and it wasn't the same way for
you either Ryan it sometimes it doesn't
require these I mean there are these
inciting incidents but it doesn't have
to be this car crash was there an
inciting incident was there an idea that
you were like oh oh [ __ ] or was there a
need that was it was missing out there
you're like I need to fulfill this I
just I just realized when I I had
written three books I had written a
thousand blog posts I think you guys are
written that much for sure and over a
hundred podcasts and and at some point I
was like huh I was like am I gonna be
the best in the world at this could I
sure I'd be the best in the world at
this and progressively I just started
thinking huh and I had thought about
different people you know that we all
know like Seth Godin and these other
these other bloggers and writers and and
and people that we really that we were
really influenced by and I thought can I
make more of an impact and and in my
life I decided that the answer would be
yes and it's amazing you often we often
cross people I think you guys cross
people from that circle all the time I
cross people that sometimes circle all
the time sometimes they just keep
persevering you guys just kept
persevering and it has done it's become
an amazing thing and that perseverance
is sometimes the right answer and then
other times the reinvention is the right
answer and you can only really know if
you you know once you choose one you
know a lot of people they will ask me
like hey Ryan or Louis you know Josh hey
Josh look you guys were in the corporate
world and then you decided to reinvent
yourselves and then you know you started
this blog and it turned into books and
the documentary and so forth and so on
they're like how did you do that and you
know what the first thing I say is is
like I did not just quit my job and
start a blog good it's the worst advice
anyone can give you
but I'm interested in you you quit your
blog and started a job so I guess just
speak to that transition a little bit
I mean it's progressive I I remember
having an idea I thought huh I'm stuck
like you guys you don't really have an
office you just you're stuck in coffee
shops all the time and I was like man
there's like no place for me to go other
than this coffee shop and I thought oh
that's interesting
and I feel like the best ideas if
something sticks with you for a long
time and you almost reject that idea and
you think nights like it's probably not
nothing but then it keeps coming back to
you like over and over and over again in
a different forum and so there was a
period of time where I thought well I'm
gonna rent a space near my house which
is still where we live in st. Henry not
far from here and and I said well I'm
just gonna give the keys to a bunch of
different people and people can show up
and they can meditate there or they can
you know relax or do whatever the hell
they want for like a couple hours and
won't be a coffee shop it'll just be our
place and I thought huh what what else
could I do with that and then
progressively now we have 500 spaces in
300 buildings you know and it's become
this really big thing and it does
exactly what that thing is
but it's because an idea that I could no
I get rid of and and and you have to try
because lots of ideas feel good for like
a short period of time but most most of
them over time you're just like this is
wait this was stupid I should not have
[ __ ] but then the idea change over time
so remember when you first were sort of
pitching it and you were talking about
you this idea that you had to me and
it's sort of a started off almost as a
meditation space almost exclusively like
or meditation loosely speaking like get
me away from the craziness of a city
especially like a place like New York
how do I get away from this for an hour
hour and a half whatever but now it's
morphed into you can have a business
meeting there you can have a therapy
session there you can you you have like
tutors who are tutor tutoring using the
space to tutor kids and I think that the
same thing has happened to us on the
other side where the idea of more so
yeah we started a blog and then people
are like hey what are you gonna write a
book I'm like
that's that's an idea and and then over
time you know we did social media and
the podcast by the way julie has started
podcasting in 2004 I think it was a long
time ago and and I remember when I first
discovered his writing it was like 2010
and man I was like I'm so glad he got
over that whole podcast phase because
that thing is never going to last and
here we are so so can you talk about
that idea maybe sometimes they change or
sometimes they grow to include more than
what you thought it was going to be yeah
I mean that's true the best ideas just
take on a life of their own
right and so what I what I always find
us I would noodle with something
everybody heroes have an idea before
then you have that idea and you'll try
to tell someone and they'll be like and
most of the time the answer is like man
and then that's okay it's just like you
mean nobody had just has only had one
idea you have tons right there's like
you'd keep throwing like a variation of
it out there and then I would I would
find a variation of that idea I don't
remember how he talked about it then and
I just throw it at people and they'd be
like that would be amazing and like over
and over and over again like that would
be amazing like I should [ __ ] do that
and and and then then that's the easy
part it's because then you're just
talking about it and then you're not
actually doing anything you're just
talking to people and the big fear if
you're someone at the very beginning and
you have a blog and you have a book even
your blog in your book is influencing a
lot of people it's like well [ __ ] well
what if I can just talk well what if I
can't actually what if I go out there
and I actually my only skill is just
talking and I can't actually do anything
else and then so you have to go out
there even if you have that fear and you
have to see you know today I was surfing
in the river in the just not far from
here and every time you hit that wave
you're like okay so a little bit bigger
than I remember
but I have no choice Here I am and you
just like try and get over it
that's beautiful is it so for people who
my guess is there are a few people in
here that are looking to re
vent a little bit or at least pivot I
mean yours was a major pivot your you
pivoted almost a full hundred eighty
degrees and some people it's pivoting
510 degrees and you still end up in a
radically different place five years
later for me I was pivoting from fiction
writing to writing nonfiction like it
was this small little thing and and and
now I write far less fiction and much
more nonfiction and everything else that
we're doing here what do you think what
do you think people need what's the
leverage that people need in order to to
pivot or to ideally reinvent themselves
I think it's pain I know that that's not
fun to hear but it's just like you've
got a you're gonna have you have to
suffer a little bit more where you are
then that place and most of the time
you're not suffering that much where you
are so you're actually like oh this is
fine I can do this
you're like you're maybe the purpose of
suffering is progressively increasing
but not really rapidly you're like I can
take this and then but eventually it's
gonna hit some threshold and you're
gonna be like I got to do this now I got
I got a switch it away cuz people really
like comfort they really do and and they
like it even if it's not in their best
interest and even if it's long term bad
the short term it's really good and
that's always true well you hang out
with us and answer some questions sure
be great yeah howdy what's your name
where you from and what's your question
hopefully in that order
hi guys my name is Dave and I'm a
minimalist hi Dave
I'm from Prince Edward Island I walk on
ice
[Applause]
which has about 700 miles east of here
north of Nova Scotia where you have been
yes where I believe Ryan once had a
shitty mix-a-lot big lobster sandwich
decision ever Josh you just asked on
podcast for callers to write down their
questions so if you don't mind it's
gonna help me be a little bit more
concise thank ya I have two ones a real
quick one why the heck are there
promotional photos of Ryan in short hair
ha ha ha Jess was just talking to me
about this was he taking the minimalist
thing too far No
so Jess Jessica Williams who was up here
in the private box seats no she's just
getting really good pictures she runs
all over her social media and that's why
our social media is so awesome these
days is because jess is one of those
Millennials who knows how to like use
all that social media stuff Oh actually
quick give her a round of applause
[Applause]
she usually live tweets from these
things as well right from our account so
you can search but at the minimalists or
the hashtag glasses now which is what
we're using for the torso all the pithy
answer she cleans them up a little bit
and puts them out there on the socials
so just a couple days ago she was like
Ryan every time I post the picture of
you with short hair people freak out
they're like they're like - Ryan cut his
hair like what's going on
so so when Josh and I first started the
minimalist like I had just left the
corporate world and like that was that
was my corporate look but if she told me
she like reserved those photos for like
throwback Thursdays now to like make it
a little bit more understandable but it
still kind of confuses people and she
was like you got we have to stop posting
you with short hair that's so funny you
asset it's funny too cuz when I when I
like grew my hair out and like you know
just stopped shaving so much my I ran
into like myoma and oppa and they saw me
for the first time they're like what are
you doing is this like a long-term thing
I think it's like this rebellious face
that I'm going through like I'll never
cut my hair dad or like it's like you
know it's it's a you know kind of a you
know a middle finger it's like the old
corporate road no no I just actually I
just kind of did it like grew my hair
out just thinking like oh you know maybe
it'll look cool and Josh is like yeah I
think I look good and I just I like it
and and it's I don't think it haircuts
as much it's great yeah I I said in
order for us to start this cult you're
gonna have to grow your hair no this is
for those of you who were dragged here
this is not a cult
sorry about that we did this we point we
do have Nikes and kool-aid out in the
lobby zoom in now for the more serious
question and I'm looking for your most
sincere response I know I'm going to get
it but I just wanted to ask for it
anyway I'm a high school math and
calculus teacher shadowed to Ryan I know
he likes that stuff it's my mission and
it's my passion
I love teaching kids but it's hard there
are days when it's hard
anybody out there was a teacher knows
that what I'd like to know from you
you've done the blog the books the
documentary the podcast and now the
touring for which were very grateful
what is the hardest thing about all of
this for you
wait a minute you get the summers off
dude I'm totally kidding like I have I
have so much respect for teachers man
please dude if I had to teach yeah give
him a round of applause absolutely
thank you
if I had to be a teacher and teach a
classroom full of students of my 15 year
old [ __ ] self like I couldn't imagine
like how to do it um wait what was the
question
yeah what's the hardest part about doing
what we're doing oh yeah yeah oh man um
you go first
yeah there's three things I hate travel
public speaking and large crowds of
people it's not that I hate those things
but it's what Julian was just saying
that those things make me uncomfortable
I'm an introvert I like spending about
80 to 90 percent of my time alone and
now I have a family I have a
four-year-old and my partner and it's
taking time away from them as well is
also difficult but I grow immensely
through through this experience and part
of the reason we do this isn't to just
get up on stage and talk it's to listen
and to understand what everyone is going
through in their own lives
and I learned something new at every
single tour stop that we go to sometimes
it's just something yeah then I'll
remember a week two weeks a month later
a year later say oh yeah I remember that
time in Jackson Mississippi when you
know this person asked us this or when
the five year old came up in San Diego
and said I'm getting rid of my extra my
clothes that don't fit anymore and and
you you you you start to learn about
people in a way that you can't learn
about people if you're just in an ivory
tower blogging behind a you know a
MacBook or something yeah I think for me
it's like the travel is hard the staying
up till midnight with the hug line
getting back to the hotel going to bed
at 2:00 a.m. getting up at 7:00 or 8:00
a.m. to head to the next city and then
doing it all over again day after day
but you know at the end of the day like
I would not change it for the world I
mean this is this is effort that I have
the energy to put in right now and I am
totally willing to do that and like I'm
so I'm the exact opposite like I'm a
huge extrovert like this is like I have
adrenaline going through me right now
people will often come up to me in the
hug line they're like you look tired and
I'm like nah man that's just the
dopamine hit me right now but it's true
it's like I really thrive off of it it's
it R it's really hard to leave Mariah
for for a few days she wasn't able to
come to this Canadian leg we are getting
ready to move to I'm just kidding will
tell you later
we're we're getting ready we are getting
ready to make a move so like she has to
be home and like kind of take care of
some stuff before we take off and yeah
there's a lot of hard things I don't
know if I could choose like one of the
hardest things but I'll tell you any any
really difficult thing that I have to
deal with it is what I do right now
isn't net positive and I think that's
really what I would I shoot for is like
anything that I do in my life any you
know social media platform I I have in
my life any relationship I have in my
life it's like is it is it actually
draining me or is it or is it in that
positive is it doing mostly positive
things for my life so yeah it's a great
question I am Joey in here so your life
has to be so different now from where it
was you're responsible for hundreds of
employees all over the world I mean
several continents at this point you
have your business is expanded to and
and you used to be I mean the guy who I
mean your guts were spilling on to like
the microphone first and then eventually
onto the books and blog and everything
else and my guess is to certainly be you
probably even have to temper that now in
a way that you you still have to be open
and honest and but it has to be such a
different world for you what is
difficult now about being the CEO of a
large company as opposed to blogging at
coffee shops well I think like
regardless like just like the teacher
exactly like this you're making a
sacrifice and that sacrifice is
worthwhile it's just that it's it's like
I'm making a sacrifice
one here is making a sacrifice it just
is that sacrifice worthwhile yeah and
you're making that decision every day
the sacrifices that I make I been
working on one thing and one problem and
attacking that one problem from its
multiple angles for some like five years
is that worthwhile every time that
someone leaves us a review every time
that someone uses our space every time
that they that they find out or they
have they do their it lets them do
something they couldn't do before you
remember that the sacrifice is
worthwhile so I'm sure you have
something like that and you know that
that sacrifice is worthwhile so I mean
that's that's just the decision that we
have to make deliberately verses by
accident and I think it's important to
note too late it may not always be
worthwhile either I mean and we have to
keep questioning it and maybe this is
the thing you will do with the rest of
your life but there may be a point as
well that you're like you have to keep
asking because if you ask and you say
yes of course the sacrifice is worth it
then you're gonna feel more convicted in
what you're doing but I also think that
if you if you ask it and you like I'm
not really sure right now at least check
your pulse
so then check it week later a month
later and and make sure that is the the
right sacrifice to be making I do have
sorry I do have one more quick thing I
wanted to add on the way down the plane
today I was listening to podcast 95
about budgeting and Ryan sounds like
you're getting close to letting go the
2004 Toyota Camry I'm a couple years
away from it okay yeah I was a bit of
advice for you Blue Book value probably
not so good but if you were to go to
Craigslist or Ebay and listed as the
minimalist tour bus
vintage condition
that's a great idea man you know what
you know what I will probably do with
that car actually when I finally get rid
of it I will probably like find someone
who really needs it and just like donate
it and Missoula Montana we have a lot of
refugees coming in from from all
different places and like that's the
number one need that people ask for and
I'm like god I wish I was in a position
right now to just like go get a new car
and donate this thing but that's a good
idea man I couldn't make a few bucks off
of it all right let's start the bidding
right now do I hear I'm just good thanks
your question thanks so much man howdy
what's your name
hi my name is Leah hey Leah welcome so
my question is really um well let me
just start I am someone who has a lot of
anxiety and I feel like once I
discovered you guys and minimalism it
sort of helped me start to let go some
of that some of that is supposed to I
feel like you said something about that
today Ryan you said oh that's supposed
to I'm supposed to get this I'm supposed
to get that and I mean it's helped me
let go of okay I don't need extra linens
or something big like maybe I don't need
to get a mortgage soon but you also
talked a lot about values and I do still
think that marriage and maybe a wedding
in the next couple of years and my
partner Matt he agrees with this it's
something that we want we want a wedding
one day and I wondered what your
opinions and ideas were about how I
could still value minimalism and that at
the same time sure so the first thing
I'll say is minimalism doesn't preclude
you from marriage right
there there was a Globe and Mail article
about us in 2012 maybe early 2013 it was
yeah well yeah op-ed piece and this this
lady wrote that these two guys from Ohio
got rid of their stuff and their wives
and moved into a cabin together and
while all of that is technically true
the the chronology of her op-ed piece
was a bit off and Ryan got married at
age 18 great idea yeah no it was so
smart at the time and and here's the
thing I'll tell you is if aligns with
your values I think it's great and I
think that as long as you've thought it
through and you have a plan awesome the
only thing I'll add to that is don't get
into debt for it there's no such thing
as good debt yeah no I would totally
echo that I think a wedding is great I
love going to weddings and celebrating
and yes like I think it can be an
amazing experience that you and your
husband can have and and the people
around you your loved ones and make it a
very intimate thing I just went to my
cousin's wedding it was great it was a
very simple and this big barn I
literally war like the this outfit like
right here to his wedding he was like
dude way to dress up I'm like we're in a
barn man but it was great it was a great
experience and yeah if you if you have
to get into debt to have a wedding and
I'm just gonna say this bluntly like
probably not ready to get married and I
can't tell you and I'm not saying that
you personally but just anyone out there
but you know at the end of the day going
into into debt for a wedding is kind of
silly and I say that because I can't
tell you how many people how many people
I know combined with like the stories
I've heard of people who you know go
have this you know
fifteen twenty thirty thousand dollar
wedding and then you know five years
later you know heaven forbid they break
up and they're still like paying off
this wedding that so yeah I you can
still embrace minimalism with a wedding
by by having a simple wedding not going
into debt planning ahead you said a
couple years that's a long time to like
save up and and to have a really nice
wedding so you know minimalism it's not
a perfect life it's not an easy life
it's a simple one and simple it's not
easy and saving up for a wedding over
the next two years probably isn't gonna
be easy but if it's something that you
two really really want to do then you
know write the plan and work that plan
thank you oh one other thing if you
suffer from anxiety like I do although I
can tell you that I'm far less anxious
than I used to be I I do tend to be a
ball of nerves most of the time and and
because of that I struggle with one of
my biggest struggles in life is enjoying
the moment like I'm always constantly
planning stuff out and like what's the
next step and where are we going here
and they Ryan and I are total opposites
so like I'm I'm planning the next you
know year and Ryan's like hey man what
are we doing today
and it works really well for us because
we trust each other and and what I'll
say is I really struggle with enjoying
the moment and it's it's hard for me and
so what you do when you get ready to get
to that stuff make sure you enjoy it
howdy hi
my name is Sophie first of all thank you
for the inspiration by listening to you
and reading all your power your work and
all that it really inspired me to make
some changes that lowered the stress and
really improved my life so I really
noticed a big change and big improvement
in my life for the last year so thank
you for that thank you I got it I gotta
say like you know it I remember in the
Corporal and every like promotion I
would get the raises I would get the
things I would get it had it had this
like diminishing return of value but
when I hear stuff like that like it
feels the same every single time so
thank you very much thank you for
supporting us it's I'm looking for maybe
more of a suggestion because I live in
this suburbs and we probably know this
that the suburbs are like the greatest
place for consumption at all like
everybody consumes everything and I'm
surrounded by people at my work also who
always want the latest things the
biggest house and everything and me and
my husband well my boyfriend we always
want to have it simple but we're always
comparing or being compared to other
people just like we don't want to buy a
house and at least every week or every
month somebody tell it tells me like why
don't you want to own the house well
your own one in two years and say no
that's not what we want now I've had a
house I've had everything like that I
don't want it anymore and we were always
confronted with all these ideas from
other people and we live with four
teenagers at home for teenagers who all
want the latest gadget and the clothes
and everything and we try to set a good
example and talk to them
but I find it difficult sometimes to be
confronted with all these people who are
looking at us like
okay you're crazy you're going you're
heading the wrong way and sometimes like
late at night we question ourselves and
say okay are we doing the right thing
yeah that's what we want okay and then
we continue on but I find it hard
sometimes
Julien you are a Mozart of confrontation
how would how would you handle something
like this if you're constantly being you
be what you're saying is you're being
judged by others judged and questioned
and sometimes I just don't want an
answer anymore I I do for my children
but with coworkers it's exhausting at
one point you know you don't want to
explain your whole life and all your
choices and when you say something they
look at you and like yeah what okay
let's go to Costco and buy some stuff so
it's they sort of don't understand and I
find it a bit difficult the the reason
they're flagging me with this is because
my job Oh Mike my entire blog used to be
about swearing and yelling at people at
some point you have to you have to just
conclude that you're different than them
and you just have to stand there and you
have to take pride in the fact that
you're different
not like better but just be like I'm not
like you and I'm just not and and and
you have to you know it makes you like a
weird almost like a statue
like and and the water is like hitting
you or like whatever you know like the
wind is hitting you and you're just like
a statue over time for the first 10
years I have epilepsy so I didn't drink
for over ten years and I think your
French cock-ups well it's it that egg
when when you're not drinking people
like the [ __ ] is wrong with that guy
you're going against current against
current and at some point you're just
like I'm just an against current person
that's just how I am
and sometimes it's it's weird sometimes
people some adult but they'll make jokes
about you that I call that guy's funny
or that guys there but ultimately like
there's the pride in who you are is
greater than all of those things I know
like it's it's a weird thing because
you're constantly confronted by social
pressure like all the time it still
happens to me happens to everybody it's
it's it's never gonna stop
it's never gonna stop and and it only
stops when you're with your people so
spend more time with your people like my
sister and my husband they they're go
they're hitting the same way so I'm very
lucky for that though that is that is
really lucky like the fact that you do
have supportive a supportive husband and
and/or boyfriend it's funny I was gonna
say if you got kids together you're
living it's okay to call him your
husband like it's so cool he had kids I
had yeah we came together so we have a
bunch of kids no it's cool I'm in the
same leg I like with Mariah and I I will
I went to her dated but like we were
snowboarding a few months ago it got way
more than a few months ago man time
flies and it was last season and I was
like hey man can I just start calling
you my father-in-law because that's
pretty much like how it's gonna be
he was like okay that's cool man he's a
really cool guy but uh but yeah I would
echo what Julian said but I I guess I
would say like why the hell are you like
spending time with people who aren't
supporting you I mean I understand that
work at work it happens but at work if
someone came out to me they're like what
are you doing what you doing it's so
your [ __ ] business I mean you could
probably say that a little bit nicer
but at the end of the day like those are
just those are just people you work with
you do not have to answer to them even
it's even if it's you're your boss like
when it comes to your personal life
philosophy whatever it may be like you
you you do not have to explain yourself
I guess I would just encourage you to
don't feel like you have to explain
yourself as much and to really like live
the most authentic life that you can
okay what's your name
my name is Julian from Montreal I have a
question we're kind in the process of
getting rid of our stuff right now it's
kind of like where maybe we're trying
like next year going like traveling
around the world with our treats young
son's we have three sons my question is
how do you get the kids in this kind of
process because like they are right now
and with their Legos without all their
toys and everything and we're trying to
say okay let's get rid of this of that
they say no I have to keep this and this
is it so how do you get the kids like
they already know that kind of like
we're not this bad okay they have stuff
but not like the other families would
try to get like few things like here and
there but it's very difficult let me ask
you this what what did it take to get
you to let go I was was before me it's
like I always been in this kind of like
way and my worst nightmare
even though what you have to get with my
kids you know I would never even had a
bunch of stuff you felt like you were a
minimalist yes okay so but but what
triggered you to start letting go of
stuff what was what was the pain point
or Julie was talking really about about
suffering it's like we heard before you
got you got the idea of you're working
for paying your stuff we're getting like
crazy with that and we're one we're
searching away to just like let go when
do
thing else with our life than just
working right wasn't why did you want to
let go because we're not happy right and
you wanted to be happy right and you
wanted to feel like there was something
better than this just consuming on
impulse right and so there's a question
I asked her in my talk I say how am I
your life be better with less right now
you have answers to that you might be
able to pretty easily rattle off five
things like you know what my finances we
better under control but guess what if
you go to your kids and say hey kid I
have a four year old if I were to tell
Ella
you know what Ella I need you to have
fewer toys because we need to get our
finances under control
she said what our finances she's on
Twitter by the way at Ellis and--which
we weed his catalogue herb life one
tweet at a time but she she is really
good at letting go of stuff now because
we've developed the habit and so the
thing that I tell parents and that I
practice myself
is something I call show tell show I
have to show her through my actions I
have to explain to her what I'm doing
then I have to show her again and then
when I explain it to her I'm gonna
explain it to her in terms that she
understands how might your life be
better with less means better finances
for you but for her it might mean or it
might mean you know I have fewer toys to
clean up and I finally have her within
the last few months understanding that
if she gets rid of something she no
longer plays with some other kid has the
ability to play with it she's finally
just barely beginning to understand what
contribution means and I think it's
she's not gonna get it overnight but
she'll get it in the long term by the
time she's an adult she'll understand
what it means to give
[Applause]
howdy hi my name is Brittany I'm from
upstate New York hey Brittany hey I just
had a quick question so a lot of us
Millennials we're graduating college and
we graduated college and a lot of debt
and I just had a quick question what's
your best advice that you can give us
like moving forward into the next step
in our life man I wish I could tell you
what your exact next step is in your
life but you know Josh and I we don't
have all the answers we got about 17 and
and they help a lot of people out but no
seriously though at the end of the day
like minimalism is not about again
living this perfect life I think for me
in and you know you know out by the way
for those who were dragged out here you
don't call it minimal as I mean call it
simplicity deliberate living whatever
you want I think living that lifestyle
what it does is it help you it helps you
pave your own Road towards the things
that are really really important so you
know the first step for me it was really
figuring out what was important in my
life and that's why I had that packing
party and then after that I started to
realize oh wow like all these things
they weren't just like weighing me down
mentally but they were actually
preventing me from from living up to my
values and beliefs like it prevented me
from focusing on my my priorities it's
funny like if you were to have asked me
like hey Ryan what are your priorities I
would have been like what my health is
my priority if I'm not healthy well then
what do I have but I was drinking a lot
doing a lot of drugs I was going out to
in the in Ohio we have White Castle like
you hit that up but like 3 o'clock in
the morning after you're leaving them
the bar and then I would say all my
relationships oh it's really you gotta
have good people in your life if you
don't have good people in your life well
then what do you have my mom lived a
half hour away I saw her maybe a couple
times a year my dad the same exact the
same exact thing hardly ever saw him
in fact my closest friends I probably
saw them the least and I was hanging out
with
instead I was hanging out with you know
networking buddies and who was important
in the community and any customers and
focusing on that so when I was you know
sitting there faced with all of my
things and realizing like why here are
these like tens of thousands of dollars
worth of things that I brought into my
life and in order for me to have these
things I've had to ignore the most
important people in my life and if I
didn't spend all this money like maybe I
actually could save some some money up
and retire you know retire early in and
actually focus on my priorities and it
really helped me see that hey my
priorities it's not what I say they are
it's what I actually do so I guess what
I would encourage you to do is really
lay out like what are those values and
beliefs like what makes you tick what
gets you excited what are your
priorities what do you need to focus on
next and that's gonna be different for
everyone the only thing I add to that is
stop and what I mean by that is the best
way to get out of a hole is to stop
digging and and debt as a whole personal
debt will prevent you from feeling free
it will prevent you from making certain
decisions you want to make in your life
I stayed in the corporate world longer
than I wanted to because I had to start
pouring every last dollar toward getting
out of debt it wasn't my money anymore
I was already spending toward the next
promotion and I had to stop in order to
get out of that crater and walk in the
direction that I wanted to walk
[Applause]
howdy what's your name my name is Rachel
I'm from Montreal as well and I'm also a
little bit shorter basically I just
wanted to say first that your
documentary was a very big inspiration
for me actually it got me out of this
place where I was kind of stuck like I
would feel when I wasn't my home alone I
would feel crowded by the stuff that was
in my place
and when I saw the movie actually that
same night I started thinking about oh I
could get rid of this I could get that I
could I started getting like freaking
out about everything that I could get
rid of and actually one thing that I
found after a certain time is I would
constantly be looking for more things to
get rid of eventually it came to this
point where it started to even be a
problem where I would have to get rid of
everything sure but the one thing that
got me stuck again at that point is even
if I was getting rid of stuff I would
get that brush when I would get rid of
something but I still don't know how to
answer the hard questions I still don't
know where I'm going I and I can't find
how to get those answers even though I
feel better in my place I still don't
know how to push this forward and go
forward like past that point of getting
rid of things our friend Rob Bell he
he's in our podcast recently and he
sometimes tells the story of a rabbi in
the first century who is travelling from
a nearby village back to his village
he's a little drunk it's late at night
he just had dinner and he's traveling
back to his village and he reached
reaches this fork in the road and he
forgets which one he's supposed to go to
get back to his village he knows that
one way is gonna take him to his village
the other way is gonna take him to a
Roman outpost and so he takes a left way
and starts walking for about a mile
one point six kilometers and wouldn't
you know he ends up at the Roman outpost
and the guard at the top of the outpost
says who are you and what are you doing
here and the rabbi pauses they said what
you say he said who are you and what are
you doing here he said how much are they
paying you he tells them it's like a
hundred dollars a day because I will pay
you twice that if you show up at my
house every morning and asked me those
two questions I think if we want better
answers we have to start asking better
questions in our life and so you might
be asking yourself certain questions
right now but what are the best
questions that you can ask yourself and
I don't know what those questions are
for you
and I gave you some earlier why have I
been so discontented who's the person I
want to become how am I gonna define
success and those are tough questions
and you know you're gonna get the answer
right the first time or the second time
but I think you'll get there if you keep
asking questions like that thank you hey
before before we move on I want to do
something we have a segment called right
here right now where we talk about
what's going on the lives of the
minimalists we got a bunch of stuff
going on and we're gonna if we have any
other questions that we answer all your
questions we ask for people back there
right we'll do a bonus we'll do some
bonus questions here in a moment but
we're doing some stuff right now I first
want to encourage you if you if you
haven't heard of breather for the folks
listed as home or the folks here
Julian's company has been expanding like
crazy I think it's you're opening one
space a day now that's true when I heard
that I didn't believe it at first I'm
like that's but that's
insane right I mean it's it's
magnificent growth but it's a as a
minimalist what you do aligns with my
values why is that because I think we
are shifting from a a culture of
ownership to a culture of access and you
don't have to own an office that costs
thousands of dollars a month in order
for you to be productive or to just get
away to have a breather of sorts and you
can do it by the hour now and that's
really what what you're offering for
people is you don't have to own this
thing you have to maintain the thing you
don't have to clean the thing because
when we buy something we don't think
about all these other costs that aren't
embedded having a cleaning staff and
having people having to paint the walls
and recarpet and and put floors in there
all these embedded costs that that you
don't think about beyond the initial
price tag of having something and you
eliminate that when you have access to
something whether that's a public park
but we don't have public parks for
office space and you're providing that
in a way I mean obviously it's it's a
public good in the sense that the public
has access to it obviously you have to
pay for it that's how a business works
and as minimalist we're not allergic to
money right it's not about being poor or
being an ascetic it's about what's going
to augment my experience of life and
what you're talking about is is a
phenomenon that's referred to in some
circles as death of the ownership
Society which means we're coming from a
world where everyone owns things because
they have to and because it's easy to a
world where access is easier than
ownership and way way way more
affordable yeah and and way less
stressful to man it's one of the reasons
we're moving so we could probably talk
about that real quick since you can just
keep it between us right we're not
announcing until this this coming
Tuesday I'm actually flying there
tomorrow to move my partner is in route
right now Rebecca and she
is she's a very small u-haul not a
26-foot truck that's the smallest thing
that you'd attached to our vehicle
basically and we are going to the place
where people go to tell stories tomorrow
I'm moving to Los Angeles California and
so is Ryan and one of the reasons is is
exactly what you're talking about it's
having access to
I mean networks of people and also
access to we want to do a lot more video
and film stuff and and obviously access
to that community but also access to
spaces you know some of my favorite
places in the country happen to be there
in Los Angeles because you have so many
people in LA that that that you can
share this space you can pay for access
I don't have to own a sauna to be able
to go to a sauna right you could just
pay to go there and and I think we're
moving more and more toward then the
more the we can outsource from having to
own the more is sort of frees up that
that weight that that's sort of
occupying the back of our minds all the
time so Julian I just want to say thank
you for the work that you that you did
that was really inspirational but what's
inspirational now is the ability to
constantly reinvent yourself to to pivot
and I'm grateful you're you're our
friend man thank you so much yeah thank
to you guys
if you'll stick around we'll do some
bonus questions but real quick we've got
a few things going on y'all heard about
the floods that are going on in Houston
right now right you've seen the the
incredible damage and it's gonna take
months honestly it's gonna take years to
repair the damage and we just started
working with a nonprofit called global
giving they are on the ground right now
in Houston and a hundred percent of the
money donated to them goes to the the
immediate rescue and relief fund of
what's going on now but also the
rebuilding of the city which is gonna
take place over 100,000 houses have been
affected by this and we don't know how
many people are dead yet we don't know
how many people are homeless we don't
know how many people are are suffering
right now and what Ryan and I want one
of our core values is contribution one
of our foundational values is
contribution and so we're doing for
those of you listening to this at home
we're doing an event in Houston on
November 5th and a hundred percent of
the profits from that event are going to
go to global giving global givings
hurricane Harvey Relief Fund
[Applause]
two or three other things we're on tour
right now we're in the middle of this 40
city towards couple s is now tour you
can find all the dates cities theatres
etcetera and les is now calm it's all of
North America and all of Canada all of
Canada is sold out so thank you for
showing up and representing Canada and
over half the cities in the United
States sold out but there are still some
tickets left in a lot of those cities
less than now calm we're coming to
Australia next year as well and so you
could check out yeah Australia you check
out the dates over there les is now calm
I'm also teaching my last writing class
for a long time so I've been teaching
writing class Phil online for the last
five years it's called how to write
better it's a two-hour workshop I do a
four-week class as well that is all
automated but I know many of you don't
have time to take on an entire four-week
class so I distilled the best parts into
a two-hour live workshop it's October
22nd how to write better or you can find
all the details for that and oh we're
building one of the other reasons we're
moving to LA is we're building a podcast
and film studio and now is where we talk
about all of our sponsors right no you
know we think advertisements suck and
you see 5000 advertisements a day I
don't want you to see five thousand and
one and so our podcast is one hundred
percent reader and listener supported
and that's thanks to you we're able to
build the podcast in film studio none of
the money zero dollars goes to me or
Ryan from the contributions we started
something called patreon it's a patreon
page where you can donate a couple bucks
per episode and all that money helps us
build this podcast and film studio so
head on over to the minimalists com
click on the donate button at the top
and you can contribute one time via
PayPal or repeatedly on patreon if you
do that we do it we're due every week
now we've been doing these private
podcasts for the last month or so and
hopefully we'll keep doing it that
frequently and right now I'd like to do
a little mini private podcast
the 600 of you and the people who are
listening at home on patreon but if you
have a question or a comment at home a
comment or a tip for any of the people
who asked questions today or anything we
talked about you can give us a call
leave us a voicemail four one six two
one nine seven eight three nine four oh
six did I say four one say you did don't
call that number that's a dilemma wait
just just just just say the number again
Sean can edit it give us a call fro six
two one nine seven eight three nine it's
my favorite part of the show where
people call in at the end and I learned
so much from other people I'm like oh
[ __ ] I'm not even a real minimalist
though I didn't think of that or that or
that we think there's a handful of
messages at the end of each episode and
so you can check that out at the end I
want to thank a few people before before
we hop off we Ryan and I we are sort of
the face of this thing but it takes an
entire team of people a couple of whom
are with us we already thanked Jess we
don't her had to get too big so let's
not thank her again but podcast Sean is
lurking in the shadows and let me tell
you before we before we give him any
applause he is he is a producer of
podcasts he is our tour manager he is
our road manager he is our book editor
he is our website editor
he is our podcast editor and he is an
all-around outstanding human being and
Sean I know that people say we couldn't
do without you but the truth is we could
but it wouldn't be nearly as awesome
brother thank you so much for being here
podcast Sean ladies and gentleman who
love you ma'am
we will hang out after this we'll be out
there in about 20 minutes or so after
this whole thing wraps up you're welcome
to come out and purchase a book if you
would like if you didn't bring your
wallet or you just can't afford a book
we're happy to buy by you once so you
can have a book on us as well we'll take
some pictures and all that fun stuff but
the last person I want to thank here
tonight is is you you decided to spend
some money to be here tonight you know
cost 25 30 bucks or if you those fancy
VIP people more than that they get first
in line access after the event but and
we're really grateful you decide to
spend some money because it allows us to
hire security to pay the staff to pay
Sean and Jessica and travel and actually
stay in a hotel believe it or not we
used to sleep on readers floors just a
few years ago or at rest stops in Ryan's
Toyota Corolla and now we have an actual
hotel room and so yes thank you for all
of that and we get to have an awesome
venue and it's because you contribute
but you contributed something much more
than that you gave up your two most
precious resources tonight your time and
your attention and we're grateful for
that and if you leave here with just one
message we hope what's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for being here yo thank you so
much Montreal hello this is Arielle from
Pensacola Florida I wanted to address
the high schooler that wanted to know if
all the hard work she was doing now was
worth graduating college debt-free
as someone who graduated debt-free I can
say yes it is although I do not fully
subscribe to the no debt is good debt I
have witnessed my friends earn less than
half of their salaries because their
money is going to paying off their
student debt I've seen my own mother
getting phone calls from her college and
being unable to get licenses across
state lines because her college would
not release her information due to debts
over 30 years old
graduating without unnecessary debt
allowed me to be the first of my friends
to start an IRA to buy a house and at
the time use the tax credit from buying
a house to buy a new car
careful planning and hard work grow
exponential benefits that you will not
be able to receive if you start your
life by entrenching it in debt being
debt-free is the best investment you can
make in yourself work hard to be heart
you can do it hey guys I'm Carly calling
from Queensland Australia
sorry about my crackling voice I'm
actually recovering from a chest
infection but I'm calling because I
heard Joshua say on an episode recently
that he didn't believe that gift-giving
should be classed as a love language
I've really been struggling with this
idea ever since I heard that because
especially now that we're heading into
the Christmas season because I'm someone
that's always got a lot of joy out of
giving gifts and I put a lot of thought
into the things that I get people this
year I'm actually even throwing a
wrapping paper party I've always hated
the waste that comes from gift wrap so
I've organised an architectural company
to save their site plans for me and
we'll decorate those at wrapping paper
when they would normally just be
recycled but getting back to just giving
as a love language I do believe that
giving presents even physical things can
be a love language and I actually think
that minimalism can help you become a
better gift giver and help you refine
this particular way of expressing love
but these days I tend to give a lot of
gift certificates for experiences as
gifts which is something I know you guys
recommend things like cinema and massage
vouchers or in the past I've even given
people hang-gliding gift certificates if
I do buy a physical thing I make sure
it's something very special that I know
for a fact the person will get a
tremendous amount of value from or that
they've been coveting for a long time I
also steer clear of anything that's
disposable poor quality or anything
that's really just a filler gift to make
a Christmas tree look more impressive
when I was a child my family did
Christmas is really big but now that I'm
a mother myself I'm not ashamed of the
fact that I only give my child a small
handful of presents but they're all very
special things that really do come from
hi my name is Teresa and I'm calling
from Indianapolis and I just found your
podcast so I'm going through randomly
and this is about podcast number 92
somebody mentioned they had a lot of
papers and they mentioned medical I just
retired from working in medical records
in an oncology office please PLEASE
obtain and keep your own medical records
scan them into a secure file the law
only requires medical facilities to keep
those for seven years and if a doctor
can't verify your previous diagnosis and
treatment it could affect your current
treatment and treatment plan so please
take care of your medical records make
them available for your next doctor hope
you don't need them but thank you much
bye
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for you gotta grab oh I bet
that you'll be fine without your team
[Music]
you
[Music]